the movie is hands Estonia hits theaters
on Friday uh sure he plays Sugar Ray
Leonard Edgar Ramirez in the starring
role plays Roberto Duran and they join
us now here in the New York City man
cave
who was approached first here to do this
movie you know what can we make can we
make a quick adjustment okay I want
I would love Edgar to have a winner's
head gear I mean can we switch come over
here oh okay
all right so we we have basketball theme
with headphones all right
he's got waiters on now wait who do you
have on you have I got Cavaliers too and
I'm sure of course you're a minority
owner with the Cavaliers yeah and you're
wearing the Knicks yeah I'm in New York
did you get a ring yes you will get a
ring it's coming yeah oh that's awesome
all right so who got approached first
diamond yeah yeah um you uh sure
actually you got approached first I mean
you've been yeah you've been on the on
board this project for logar so when
Jonathan reached out to me obviously
there's a it's an easy sale because I
dance I perform there's some you know
idea of improvisation with with dance
and performance so we'll make it easy
for me to pick up sugar in Linda's
movements and that was only the
beginning but when you read the script
you recognize that this is a real like
substantial piece of art and I mean he's
amazing this was an independent and I
thought that I knew enough about Sugar
Ray Leonard you know but I only knew the
perspective that was the fact that he
was an Olympic medalist the fact that he
was celebrated as a box to the fact that
he was endorsed and as an
african-american that was pretty amazing
you know and but when I read the script
I've really got a different perspective
and understanding and respect for
Roberto Duran in his full story so so
then when they approached you Edgar
yeah what did you know about Roberto
Duran at the time well I I knew I knew
the legend you know the myth um
Venezuela and and my dad was a llama has
always been a huge fan of Roberto Duran
but when all of this that it's
portraying the film went down I was
three years old so I I just you know
knew the stories some of it I mean Manos
de Piedra which is you know hands of
stone in Spanish was the name that
always resonated in my childhood but I
didn't know in much detail how
fascinating his life was until it was
approached by Jonathan to the film but
and then De Niro comes on when does De
Niro come on board here De Niro was on
really job before Oscar I oh he really
championed for this film to be made
because I thought sure said is that mean
it took them he didn't seven years to
finally put the movie together and to
raise the money and then the movie also
went through different incarnations
until you know we we got it made so I
actually was the last the last person to
join the project how long does it take
before you call De Niro Bob because once
you get to Bob or Bobby yeah then you
made it you're in the club how long did
it take before you go bother yeah I
think Jonathan gave us all the licence
to go for Bob Jonathan Jacobo Woods the
director because they had you know had a
really great relationship I heard him
calling you know Robert Bob a lot so I
said okay you didn't do mr. De Niro when
you first met him did ya okay I just you
know I mean by the way he's such an
amazing icon and it takes an icon to not
be in the perception of who he is when
you meet him you meet a real person you
meet a person who is open on he's like
it's just love and passion and support
and you can't help but feel like he's an
uncle he's a dad absolutely no yeah a
godfather
yeah but Edgar can you ask Bob to go
back mr. De Niro Bob to go back and you
know
can you ask him to go back and help you
when he did the transformational work
with Jake LaMotta was there anything
that you could ask him to do that he
went through that could help you become
Roberto Duran well the things that by
the time we I mean Bob is very
respectful of everyone's process and he
was very he was very he he was very
empathetic I mean he really understood
what Russia and I went through because
he had gone through that you know when
he did a Raging Bull so he was very
sympathetic he he he knew that I mean we
were fighting for so many hours I mean
the whole process took over a year of
Fighters we had to become fighters in
order to to portray these characters
there's no way to imagine a boxer you
can not imagine a boxer boxing affects
everything in the way you talk in the
way you walk and the way you shake hands
there's a very particular way for boxers
to shake somebody else's hand because
they need to protect their hands so it's
very in the way you tell a joke and wait
explain that well you you just it's it's
a softer is a software it's a soft issue
I mean some somebody oh by the way some
boxers don't even shake yeah because
you're not heard many a time someone
could cut their hands you know you
really have to be protective of your
hands yeah did it ever get serious
between you two in the ring in the ring
no you know I think I think that we
wanted I could speak for myself yeah of
course you know I think we wanted the
the the rounds to be as clearly
representative of what they actually
were so I think I spent more time
studying it even more than the
choreography because we we did exchange
back in the you know in the back before
we went out and also - we had some
training sessions together and he was
saying he had such an inquiry he had
such an amazing schedule like I don't
even know how he was able to get to the
actual tanks every time I would reach
out to him he'd be actually out filming
but um I spent so much time studying
those fights that when we came together
I just had memorized it all in my head
in addition to the choreography so we
were very mindful EP of each other there
was no not too many slips oddly enough
we didn't really take too many you know
blows or hurt each other he actually
ended up having other accidents yeah
actually yeah I mean yeah we were we
were very serious as he said in trying
to really pay honor to some of the
greatest fights in boxing history that's
for sure we had a lot of fun and we and
we're very we're very obsessive so to
speak so we were really paying attention
to every detail but in terms of getting
hurt after hours and hours of fighting
oh sure as Sugar Ray Leonard in the ring
and then plus other fights you know that
you you could you that you're gonna see
in the film with some real fighters who
were actually you know the cane and we
kind of fight who's a real fighter the
guy who played Buchanan the only
injuries that I got in the film were
from the actresses ironically ironically
women hurting you man in that the only
the only time the only two times that I
got hurt was by journey pictures of wife
the same who played my wife Juanita his
weapon EDA she accidentally in a scene
that you guys are gonna love you're
gonna you're gonna know which scene that
is when you watch the film things were
flying around and then one of those
things landed on my face and cut my nose
but it was accidentally of course it was
just in the heat of the moment because
we were all very passionate in this film
and then and then there's another scene
that you guys are gonna know which one
that is where my wife played by Ana D
Armas the Cuban actress who played
felicidad River to the Ron's wife she
she called me gross and and then she
eventually hit me in the head and I got
a baby so you know so you know these so
we meant hurting you yeah right the
movie is hands to stone it hits theaters
on Friday we're talking to Usher and
Edgar Ramirez
Edgar playing Roberto Duran how much of
sugar ray was in Roberto durán head in
what games but what yeah I mean I mean
that that's actually and and and for
everybody but especially for boxing fans
I think that one of the most amazing
things about this film and what makes
the film so unique is the fact that it
really explores the circle
Nicoll aspects of the sport and and he
shows you that is basically a mental
sport and referred to Duran was the was
the master of screwing with people's
mind you know and and actually when you
talk when you talk to sugar
III I mean coincidentally I ran into
Sugar Ray Leonard for the first time
then that before the premiere it was two
nights ago it was my first time first
time that I mean that I met um a Sugar
Ray in person and and yeah he's still
he's still a little bit freaked out by
by how hard I ran in the you know in the
first fight you know like really messed
with his head and then also became you
know was also trapped by his own
strategy later on but you're gonna see
that in the film but a lot of it is that
we think Duran now when we think No Mas
and he was such he was so much more than
that
yeah and Sugar Ray Leonard was so much
more than just those fights with Duran
but when I say Roberto Duran most people
think he quit well the movie makes you
clear of who he is in the history this
is a film about - de piedra the hands of
stone and that psychological warfare
that most athletes boxers understand is
a matter of intimidation and he was
incredible that as a matter of fact it
was one of the great things that helped
prepare me for Sugar Ray Leonard right I
read his book and he speaks in detail
about how intimidated he was by Durant
he was an animal you know yeah you know
he'd never seen or experienced anything
like that and I hardly enough because
it's not like he didn't have opponents
who were aggressive in the ring but this
man had no barriers he talked about his
wife he insulted him he insulted him he
racial slurs all of these things that
psychologically tore down or created
another story a different narrative for
him which is why he fought him you know
flat-footed and then there's the second
fight which is in history known as you
know this this moment that not many
people understand but I think in many
ways he awakened something in Sugar Ray
Leonard
he gave him edge he made him understand
that it's more than just about being an
Olympic
listen doing things for honor but also
to the the other aspect of the sport
your footwork I mean just in how you
perform yeah
do you see boxers like is there a
correlation between having that artistry
to be able to have some theater footwork
showmanship the type of confidence that
you have to have coming into the ring is
no different than standing in front of
62 1812 or 2,000 people you have to have
this you know this I don't know man well
I don't know what the word will forward
it properly depict it but you have to
have this this confidence you know that
you that you can dominate and and and
that's something that I think all of
them mastered and we were only acting in
the space of course we prepared like
boxers but me you can't live up to the
type of pressure that their boxers are
under through yeah because actually the
audience becomes also another opponent
because you're there you have this guy
in front of you who's ready to beat the
hell out of you and then suddenly you
you see these two guys who are these
Titans and then you have the audience
and the audience is projecting
everything on you there are frustrations
their fears their aspirations and
whenever something goes wrong there they
can turn against you and that you have
to zoom all these people out you have to
really stay in the ring and focus and
and and you have to stay in the zone
while people are throwing things on you
they're they're they're insulting you I
mean people who have never you know
terrain I mean there have never gone
beyond just lifting their their their
arm to drink their beers and they have
their big bill and say you you punch
like a girl you and he's like man he's
like those who can yes this he can yes
what he said pussycat you know you're a
[ __ ] cat you're a kitten you know and
then sorry I just got lost in
translation this is my accent
I apologize you nobody I apologize to
all those boxers don't make me knock
down here no no man no worries I would
never do you guys do if you went into
the ring and fought well you got it you
got to see his real life if you I put
boxing gloves on you uh-huh
well I mean we both did the work I think
I'm prepared I feel like I'm a weapon
it's better the premiere or the Cavs
parade oh man you know I was I wasn't
there for the parade what happened I
happen to be out of the country at the
time I have a day job man so you didn't
think the cabs were gonna win absolutely
11 years after after an incredible
investment nah I was very very happy for
the cash but you say which was better
yeah all of it man and I've been
fortunate to be able to experience all
of it and I'm really excited about the
potential of this amazing story being
told about Manos de Piedra hands of
stone by Edgar Ramirez Roberto durán I
mean it's it's really been a labor of
love you know and the idea of this this
film properly depicting the reality of
what it is to to box and also to you
understand the most intimate details of
the boxing world the political side no
boy no the business of it what it really
is about I mean a boxer who spent it
sometime it's a poor man's sport
right it starts that way and then
obviously when you know the ego and the
inflation of the ego becomes a part of
it what happens do you know what is your
measure of success and when you've
obtained that what can you stay hungry
today can you stay hungry can you stay
humble is it's still about family and I
think ultimately in the end it's gonna
be your film that everybody's gonna find
something to love in you know there's
there's the political side that it
touches on a little bit but it
definitely gives you a very broaden
perspective about the boxing process
mentally the sport the physical aspect
that I was talking to somebody from the
W
be a last night they were like I can't
believe how incredible you guys were
able to tell this story because not many
people understand all of those details
yeah and you guys captured all of it
yeah
so I make it make it accessible for for
people who pala necessarily are familiar
with with boxing and and the movie
really gets in the boxers head you know
so you read explores what goes on in
your head so um we're very excited yeah
I think that it's a great film not only
for boxing fans but for everybody it's a
hands of stone uh sure play Sugar Ray
Leonard Edgar Ramirez that [ __ ] can't
plays Roberto Duran and you can see it
nationwide on Friday thank you for
coming at you thank you we'll be back
after this I say Richard the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience